ah seriously I'm not talking to you I'm
mad at you oh no really
okay I want you just to walk around in
circles
yes fort lays down is my favorite thing
to teach you're probably asking yourself
how a stork a girl and a baby wound up
in this situation let me go back and
start at the beginning of the story Dona
you know I built my office entirely out
of glass even though birds can't see
glass
I do not Monday it'll all be yours
starring any monumental screw-up
orphan tulip jr. a tulip is just fine
orphan hurts my heart
that's a quail and EMU there's a chicken
they cannot fly she's helping us achieve
our dreams what is that dorks don't
deliver babies anymore if this baby
finder family then maybe I can find mine
you'll find your family you think for
sure it's crazy we're delivering a baby
if anyone finds out about this I am dead
meat powder I don't know what you're
talking about
no man I will not be your friend
destroyed the whole room we have to
replace the chimney with this light for
when the storks deliver my baby brother
what he said dad's a fun mom to me
but down baby are you in love I am in
luck are you in love I'm in love too
angry I agree I agree I agree
in the beginning
storks delivered babies
it wasn't always easy
no matter how tough or impossible or
brutal or inhumane or savage we would
triumph over adversity thank goodness we
don't do that anymore
now storks deliver packages per quarter
store.com your Philip there's one less
baby to deliver this is a family that
never got the baby they asked for if
this baby finds their family then maybe
I can find mine let's do it let me show
you how to fight it hello I'm a bird I'm
pretty sure I know how to
you see what yep I peed in the seat
mower falling my old nemesis
I built my plaintiff AI my parent you'll
find your family
don't worry honey everything's gonna be
just fine
for ball this happening
sorry this tastes like flour
okay stand aside are you in love I am in
luck are you in love I'm in love too
angry I agree I agree I agree it's like
good best friend that live together mom
dad I've decided I want a baby brother
your store delivery service our son
really deserves a baby brother PS you
have no skills
I saved this company by cutting out a
baby's added to package deliveries
Monday it'll all be yours going any
monument to screw up julep but what is
that ko beads storks don't deliver
babies anymore if anyone finds out about
this I am dead meat baby powder homing
pigeon powers occupied
no no just a brief exposure to baby
cuteness can ruin your life
this film is not yet rated
it's an image as old as time a baby
swaddled in white delivered by the stork
how quaint but you'll find here on stork
mountain we take baby delivery seriously
I'm here to finally unveil our new and
improved human infant production
facility we have perfected and
streamlines the process devising the
zero mistake workflow trademark using
the most cutting-edge technology coupled
with over 75 years of hard-won
experience our new process has been
described as perfect precise flawless
ideal immaculate no problemo
era proof to prevail the opposite of the
Titanic just so you can hear the four
most precious words in human language
googoo gaga
so when you're looking for baby deliver
you can turn on the stork delivery
service
lady come my lady
you